The pressure is hilariously building on lying
Republican Congressmen George Santos or Anthony
Davis, older or whatever his name is, to resign.
Yesterday, there was an event held by the Nassau
County Republicans and a bunch of other officials,
and it is just delightful. And I am increasingly
hopeful that they are going to force this
guy out. And, you know, they love to say,
oh, they're trying to destroy his career.
He lied about everything. He deserves to
have his career destroyed. Sometimes it's right
for you to lose your job, folks. Here is Nassau
County Republican Chair Joseph Cairo saying
that George Santos should resign immediately.
The reason this is the district he represents,
that's why we're talking about Nassau County to.
County Republican Committee. Nor should he serve
in public service or as an elected official. He's
not welcome here a Republican headquarters for
meetings or at any of our events. As I said,
he's a disgrace to House of Representatives, and
we do not consider him one of our congresspeople.
Today, on behalf of the Nassau
County Republican Committee,
I am calling for his immediate resignation.
Now, this is all great and I love it. And we'll
get George Santos his reaction momentarily.
Increasingly, it seems as though Nassau County
Republicans knew that this guy was lying about a
bunch of this stuff. It's not been definitively
proven, but it's increasingly looking that way.
So really what they're having a problem with is
that this makes them look bad. I don't know that
they actually care about George Santos lying about
everything. It's that now everyone knows George
Santos lied about everything and it makes them
look really bad. It's still very funny. Here is
a claim that George Santos claimed he
was a volleyball star at Baroque College,
which he didn't actually graduate
from, and that he had a champ,
a volleyball championship. Look at this. Can
you just explain what was on that resume?
Well, to my recollection, it said he went to
Baruch College, said he went to NYU. He later
or perhaps at the end through I didn't intended
that he sought a master's degree, said that he
worked in finance. I don't recall. Was it Citi?
Citigroup, I think, said he was very successful.
Told me personally that that he had made a lot
of money at that age and was successful in life.
We got into it, started getting personal about
the fact that he came from a poor background,
but that he was able to be very successful. Told
me. I remember specifically I'm into sports a
little bit, that he was a star on the volleyball
team, that they won the league championship.
What can I tell you? It is.
A joke. But also the joke is these Republicans
who it seemed like they had these suspicions
for a long time, and now all of a sudden
they're like, well, the guy should resign. I
actually remember when George Santos developed an
incredible surgical technique back in the 1930s,
and it was a real, real big advancement in
medicine, as you can imagine. Next, we heard from
Republican Congressman Brian Fitzpatrick. Now,
this is meaningful because this is Fitzpatrick,
who is a sitting member of Congress saying
he shouldn't be here. And, you know, Kevin
McCarthy has resisted saying this type of thing.
Fitzpatrick says he simply should not be here to.
Happen before the House leadership. You're part
of that, joins the calls for Santos to resign.
Yeah, thanks for having me, Andrea.
I don't think you should be here,
that's for sure. But there's a process in place
that has to apply equally to all members from both
parties in both chambers. And that's the House
Ethics Committee. As your panel just put it out,
to the extent that there's concerns about how
long that would take, we should just have an
expedited review. There's got to be a system in
place as consistently applied across the board.
All right. So anyway, kind of playing a both
sides sort of thing, but he is saying Jorge
Santos should be here. Then we heard from
Hempstead Town supervisor Donald Clavin,
who says that the guy is a joke and he's making
them a joke. And it is true. They were already
a joke, though. That's the thing. He's just
George Santos is making the more of a joke.
You see a unified voice here. Now, what? He's
unified the country in their opposition to him
is a national joke. Is an international
joke. True, But this joke's got to go,
right? And his on us calling him for to resign
immediately. Not tomorrow, not next week. Today.
All right. So George Santos confronted at
the House of Representatives yesterday by
Rachel Scott. Will you resign? He says
that he will not take a look at this.
I will not, as we're going to need a
little bit of me, a little space here.
The New York Republicans are
calling you a disgrace. You will
not resign. What is your response when you
get in the elevator from the top committee?
All right. So off goes Congressman Santos, Duvall
da, or whatever his name is. I really hope they
push this guy out. They say, you know, everything
else aside, Republican come. Complicity in this.
They knew. When did they know while this differed
that Republicans are dishonest? I hope this guy
gets pushed out and I hope it happens soon. Let's
talk about a couple other George Santos lies.